[Music]
kind of a goofy mishap for President
Obama yesterday I don't know if he saw
this when President Obama stopped at a
diner yesterday in Colorado a young
female college student accidentally
spilled yogurt on him yeah
after hearing this Bill Clinton said of
course yogurt that's what I should have
said
[Applause]
he wants to go back and can we talk
about this now it's crazy
good day for a Mitt Romney yesterday
yesterday Mitt Romney won all five of
the primaries all five yeah yeah you see
apparently when you buy four primaries
you get the fifth for free they punch
your card and they love that yeah
yesterday the Dalai Lama said he loves
george w bush as a person but not as a
president he said yeah yeah when asked
for comment george w bush said i love
him as a dolly but not as a llama
probably probably Center all snippy life
- hey Burger Kings in the news yeah what
a misspent whoo you only get so many in
life Burger King announced that all
their chickens and pigs will now be
raised cage free well in response
chickens and pigs said that's cool now
let's talk about the part where we get
turned into sandwiches good enough hey
in New York Sofia Vergara was that wow
the fleet's in town all right hey
he mentioned Sofia
it's like a naval base in 1946 in here
in New York Sofia Vergara was denied
entrance into a nightclub because she
didn't have ID yeah actually she did
have it but she held it up here
[Applause]
look somebody gave you a mop yeah no
these are roses for microphone oh I'm
sorry
a mop I saw a mop this place is a mess
yeah it's now the law in Southern
California that police must screen all
adult films to make sure condoms are
being used yeah
which explains the LAPD's new motto to
protect and perv
that is their job now I have to watch
every new porno right right and they'll
probably give it to someone that doesn't
like it but just a punish sigh I don't
want to see that goes against God these
people probably aren't married yeah
[Applause]
tomorrow we're not gonna be at the show
we're gonna we're gonna be police
officer the police academy with our the
two newest recruits here for porn do you
here's your gun we won't need it where's
the porn where is it got some celebrity
news singer Chris Brown is selling
pitbulls on the web did you know that
yeah apparently he doesn't want to live
with anything that can fight back
[Applause]
[Music]
big news about the kardashians the
kardashians signed a deal for three more
seasons of their reality show
yeah when asked what they plan to do for
three more seasons the Kardashians said
some Lakers some Clippers and a college
soccer team
[Applause]
[Music]